i'm here with Flickr and a number of our
members have been requesting that we buy
them donuts and we decided that you know
our members deserve doughnuts we have a
group for just about everything and we
as users ourselves we look through and
we find interesting things and the we
demand Donuts group is something we
could all really get behind and we
believe in the mission the we demand
donuts group has been active since
january of 2007 a man named Jake Rome is
the founder of the we demand Donuts
movement he's a true patriot I think in
HBO does another mini series after the
John Adams one it's going to be about
there cuz you know Donuts
you